now talking of mining people's lives for
drama and comedy mere Mowgli's things
happen to you like your is it your house
in near Dover oh yes yes because I do
rent my house to other people house to
France which is very important in this
story and it's 425 pounds a week for
seven nights it's really cleaner yes yes
anyway one one day I got a call from the
police and they said are you the owner
of the gun emplacement and I said yes
they said are you aware that it's been
used as a drop for criminals to get rid
of their drugs or you know it's a drug
drop yes phrase and I said well of
course I didn't know what do you mean
and they said well people have rented it
they were a gang a gang they took my
house and they dropped the drugs in the
bay or they and there was a helicopter
that came on the roof it's a flat roof
yes and they they had cocaine they had a
million pounds worth of worked no no it
wasn't like a little thing this was
thirteen million Jesus Christ that was
like oh yeah listen I'm days wholesale
well of course I was horrified because I
didn't know I mean I don't have anything
to do with the people that rent I know
just take the money I was well I could
get more for it because it's really
lovely was when it was reported of
course in the Daily Mail all the people
online said oh she must be in it Miriam
Escobar
[Applause]
[Music]
you